hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the role of LC ms/ms
spectrometry and diagnosis of various
endocrine disorders
I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking site and we are proud
to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information please
visit us at www.americanoutback.net
this presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits I would now like to
introduce today's speaker
Ravinder Singh dr. Singh is the director
of the Mayo Clinic and irken laboratory
he has focused an area of investigation
that has broad applicability to the
field dr. Singh studies the application
of liquid chromatography tandem mass
spectrometry LC ms/ms
to clinical laboratory analysis many of
the methods that dr. Singh developed are
now considered reference methods they
have subsequently been utilized for
standard method standardization efforts
as well as to establish clinical disease
correlates which he has published with
his collaborators
dr. singh's work has directly
contributed to improving methods for the
clinical diagnosis of Cushing's disease
Pio chromatin site OMA and congenital
adrenal hyperplasia continues to work to
discover in ative innovative ways to
better understand the use of LC ms/ms in
providing patients with faster and more
accurate diagnosis I would now like to
turn the presentation over to dr. Singh
Thank You Brenda I would like to thank
level it's also co-hosting this talk and
definitely appreciate attendance coming
online and joining me today as alive and
if you will be joining us later they'll
be greater as well so the topic which
I'm the talk today is role of Helsing
and I same a spectrum between diagnosis
of various endocrine disorders and I
have the privilege of working at Mayo
Clinic for last 15 years and have been
experienced in the role of this
technology in the clinical environment
so the objectives I have today would be
that I would like to discuss some
strengths of 10 and a spectrum between
clinical lab to have a better patient
care but every technology comes with its
cost and other technical challenges and
who some of my examples will also
highlight them outline of the table
would be that I would like to discuss
some issues later with the course or
testing for the diagnosis and screening
of Cushing's disease or syndrome like to
also spend a little bit time on
congenital adrenal hyperplasia and I'm
sure in the end I would like to finish
with a little more discussion on sexy
roids and what indeed so here is a
patient who looks like he has a
questions disease and that's what
clinicians are educated and taught in
the medical school the patient has wound
faces and has a hypertension and is
obese and if we look at the back may
have from fatty pads as well but
recognizing a patient who has a real
tumor versus in general because obesity
is very common in the u.s. is the chair
in which our clinician colleagues have
to work with cortisol is secreted from
the adrenal gland and this particular
cartoon just shows that linear glands
are located at the top of the kidneys
and the generation of the coins
or clearly is regulated by Pichet free
Hartmann which is called ACTH and NEC th
will act on the adrenal gland Avedon
gland will make or dissolve and if the
core is always more than what the
physiology requirements are that it will
negative message to the RT receptor and
the ACTH secretion will go down so
secretion of cortisol in a normal
individual is very well regulated
mechanism but unfortunately if somebody
has the pitch in treatment that means
it's the unregulated secretion of ACTH
or somebody has a two minute the appeal
and that means the cortisol is also
created unregulated manner and those are
called Cushing's disease or Cushing's
syndrome this is the cross section of
the adrenal gland this top yellow part
is called cortex in the ground dusty
color is called medulla the inner
medulla is responsible for the secretion
of catecholamines which are dopamine
epinephrine and norepinephrine and
adrenaline is also the name it is
commonly used in Europe but the cortex
is responsible for the secretion of
steroids then physicians are doing the
workup to confirm where the patient has
a suti tumor or the ability to what they
would like to order in addition to be a
CT yet a number of cortisol tests and
some of those tests are listed here it
could be here on pre cortisol which has
been considered to be gold standard for
a long time and then patients can also
be told to collect plasma cholesterol
and the new tests which have entered
their clinical field is platinum
recording so midnight plasma cortisol
and midnight cell recorders all like I
mentioned before the symptoms you saw in
the patients with the cushion disease
are pretty common office into what we
see in the general population is the
obesity is increasing so some of these
diseases and symptoms are also
associated with the hypercortisolism
is the chairman for the position to find
that one rare patient who can be cured
with the surgery by removing the tumor
from the pituitary or from their billion
plants the steel whites are complex Emma
likes in circulations most of the time
then the position orders
Steve wider cortisol we give the
position back it totals a cortisol in
blood which is the sum of the free
cortisol coils will bind to the binding
protein for example quarters or binding
globulin or quotas or binding albumin
but it is a form of be harmed which is
being used in some cases is called by
available which is the sum of the three
plus albumin and of course free is a
spirit itself but also the steroids in
human circulation had a great short
half-life
they are very bioactive and working on
your body has to clear them but for
cleaning in the year end they need to be
conjugated to the glucometer and
sulfates which increases their polarity
and helps in getting excreted in the
unit the steroid testing in the clinical
lab or in research ism is something that
you have we have been known for a long
time and very first time
dr. Zimmerman had this essay in 1935
where it was a company metric reaction
where we could look at the metabolites
or cortisol and the Android in them and
used to be called a 17 keto steroids
1952 the paper chromatography was
brought in two years and it helped in
separately in various tea lights one in
the other and then the later that switch
to the column chromatography and
detection by some kind of color metric
in many 80s the kamagra field was joined
with the flame ionization detector where
one was able to use meters long column
in gas chromatography but then using
flame ionization detected where you were
able to burn the steve wright as a
carbon source and then get the signal
the great whale in Oasis were discovered
in 1980s and the Nobel Prize was given
to doctor
yellow for making this as is available
and in this case one could be used the
antibodies against very small
concentrations of steroids which for
example could be the unconjugated
steroids for plasma steal wives and
before that all these essays were used
for the urine metabolites only but very
quickly it was realized that at low
concentrations there are interferences
whichever possible in the serum antibody
assays then conformation we had to use
GC mass spec assay but the GC mass spec
was very laborious and it was not very
practical for most of the clinical lab
and they did rely upon the amino acids
only in extreme situations GCMs worst
practical and usable as a clinical lab
we have number of technologies that are
disposable for example radium in MSA if
we have to develop any Ness which is not
commercially available we can get an
antibody in these radioactivity which is
of course not very attractive to the
people who work in the lab then
radioactivity can be replaced by the
chemiluminescence or we can use enzyme
like amino acids or fluorescence or
chemiluminescence as is but if you would
like to remove the interferences from
the plasma and use proper technique then
again we have many choices for example
GCF aidid LC UV or electrochemical GCMs
lcms or LC ms/ms are also called 10mm s
ideally clinical lab would like the lab
should be clean and everything highly
automated and having all these analyzers
communicating with the automation line
and all these things less being reported
to the physicians computers as quickly
as possible and we are proud that some
testing is recorded there to the
physicians in 30 to 60 minutes and by
the time patient goes back to the
appointment
that is also available but the topic
today is that LC ms/ms has filled the
gap either because of the limitations of
some of the universes or some problems
with the amino acids so here is an
example here that we will have three
kinds of asses in the immediate
categories in this particular cartoon
will highlight that you can detect a
analyte which is like a protein here by
using the sandwich acid where you can
help capture antibody which will bind to
the antigen and you can wash the matrix
and other interference and then between
the sink and anybody which has a label
on it
and then you can detect the
concentration of the analyte the other
possibility is that the analyte could be
very small molecular weight like
cortisol but in that case you cannot use
a second antibody you have to rely upon
the own single anybody but in that case
you have to use a labelled a tracer
which is a competitive in university so
some of the limitations of the
comparative amino acids are that the
antibody can have a cross reactivity
with the steroid or Steve word conjugate
and in addition this particular such in
the right show that dynamic range of es
is very limited if you notice that the
lower concentration the change in the
signal is very small and the same is
true at the high end so we have a very
small dynamic linker at the SA it is
useful for clinical purposes most of the
manufacturers who make many nurses will
check the cross reactivity with the
antibody units in the S is at least the
previous interferences which could be
steel white meta Polites austerity
precursors
him is a great example that one of the
vendor have tested the cross reactivity
of the cortisol antibody against Petra
hydrocortisone the cortical stearin
code is known and 11 P obstacle is the
one at 21 the obstacle is all and here
is a drug
is commonly used premise alone and
premise on and seems like this
particular integral he had a very high
cross reactivity that this particular
steel would so if these patients are on
these drugs which in the limit are
publicly used for limited arthritis or
for joint pains then in that case the
accordance will result will not be
reliable from the amino acids and
physicians have known this for a long
time and they have been asking again
it's an example of a citation in 99 dr.
Murphy has said why the lab still
keeping continues using the amino acids
then we know we have these problems by
using antibodies so at one time in our
lab we had these three methods live
because in two thousand or so we were
using the year employee code is all acid
by using one of the automated asses even
after extraction but if you notice here
the reference rate for cortisol 108 the
high end but because there were some
interferences physician will call the
lab and we use remember samples on HPLC
in unique but then that be also universe
not perfect either then we used to run
once a month
LCMS technology which was like old-style
math specs the point on this slide is
they did notice here is that by in the
United States that happened it was up
208 but by the HPLC as is the cortisol
was 55 so that means the antibody didn't
had a cross reactivity with some other
metabolize it questioning maybe it was
with the Corazon
here's an example here where the sample
was analyzed because that is also not
acceptable to a clinician for
immunoassay but if you notice they are
even after spending log of Labor to
extract a sample you spend 30 minutes on
that plc that UV detector was not very
specific these this vertical steel rod
still interfered in the middle here with
the cones or the important stone and it
means it was not the best case scenario
so this particular sample was run
further by the mass spec and where it
was a much better signal-to-noise for
the coral and cortisol and we did not
see the effect of the other three words
but now instead of using lc-ms most of
the big reference labs and good-sized
clinical labs are using LC and SNS where
you don't need 20 minutes retention time
rather if you can get results within few
minutes for both coil and code is long
and you can also use it to understand to
account for any losses during the
extraction or any expression of an
aspect or any expression in a needle or
be HPLC system so question is is it
worth going to the tenon aspect word
since the amino acids and this
particular slide will show the answer
should be yes that because the materials
are not comparable that be ghosting
their method which is the LC cannabis
method the problem was not only that the
slope was only 0.35 but in addition the
correlation is only 0.5 a good message
comparison should have slope of 1 + R
square of greater than 0.9 or higher so
that means the minimize is recovering
more than just a chorus or paralysis
unpredictable for certain samples
so in 2000 or so in 1998 we had many
many compelling amino acids because like
were put together by one of my students
unique here and we used to have no mass
back in 1998 we had a lot of at PLC's
but by 2009 we were able to convert all
the amino acids for small molecular
weight stream lines or other adult drugs
and amino acids to be ms/ms and at that
time we had 58 triple quads in a lab
environment and we were able to convert
a message from HPLC and GC NS also to be
10 min ms so currently we have with
significant Sara blogging important
aspects asses in the multiple labs we
have also one essay not a pathology lab
biochemical in a liquid in the world
screening in the number of essays called
vascular averages you get and open labs
using 28 taking tests to be done by Dan
aspect and on toxicology is also using
number of methods for drugs and toxic
toxic substances so this is what it
looks like in Big Rapids lab it's almost
like a very high dense population to
learn aspects and some labs have gone to
increase the throughput have a very
complicated HPLC in front of the mass
spec so in order to set up this
environment you do need an investment
which is expensive but you also be very
highly qualified and clean people to go
from an automated analyzer she will be
manual mass spec asses because all these
asses will be considered as lab develop
test and they are not approved by the
odds and aspect members for clinical
views that means every land has a
responsibility to make sure they do a
very rigorous validation and that would
include precision which we
be in trial inter precision accuracy
method compare which will be not in
comparison and recovery Nick make sure
that we have a good rapport you arrange
in reference range of course you need to
determine energy and loq and make sure
the mass spec materials are so specific
it is relatively more specific than the
businesses but again we have to make
sure that all the possible trucks and
metabolites are not interfering in the
mass spec essays so this particular
slide shows that if you could provide a
good test to the clinician and then that
helps in their patient care so patient
on my left had a tumor which was taken
out and after the surgery his education
became normal
otherwise this patient may have died
within five years
if this patient's diagnosis was missed
because of the inaccurate cortisol si
so the codons our testing is very pretty
color and one should look at the
advantages and disadvantages of latest
technologies
sometimes Cushing's can also happen
because of the exogenous Teno ideas and
here was a young girl in their clinic
who was using steel white maybe one year
bad pulled some knee pain and had all
the symptoms of Cushing right and she
had gained weight and the physicians
clinicians did all imaging and all the
blood work really working we could not
confirm that this particular girl had a
tumor in that case physician we went to
the history and asked a lab should be
checked whether this patient still has
the steel right which she was using this
interesting example that we do see Lord
of Steel words coming out in the market
but unfortunately a lot of safety data
is not available and some of these team
words have very similar structure and
chemical formula to whole soul and
vessel reason they may cross track with
the antibodies so
have to develop MC MSM assassins for
various keywords to confirm if the
patients are taking and your pistol
rights when we developed assassin tested
this patient sample we were fortunate to
see that we were able to see small
amount of triamcinolone se tonight which
is also known as Kenalog which this
patient was taking almost an air bag but
somehow this was deposited or stored in
the station and was being released at
the small amounts so that was the reason
this patient was having symptoms which
you've got resolved after one year of
discontinuation of the steroid and their
salt on this trip for the clinician so I
would like to talk about that lcms can
develop multiple accesses for multiple
steroids not only for drugs or exogenous
tealights there the sensitivity may not
be as it challenged worse is when you're
looking for endogenous T rights they
exist in very small concentrations and
the steelwork pathway is very complex
and complicated and if you notice here
as the enzymes are involved for example
21 hydroxyl is enzyme work and work 17
hydroxy progesterone 221b obstacle
dissolve between them convertible Israel
and there is a disease if there is the
absence of the 21 hydroxyl a best girl
congenital adrenal hyperplasia and the
patients can have symptoms in their
newborn and I will shield the picture of
that so here are two sisters the first
sister was born with the disease called
congenital in drowsier because she
didn't have the enzyme or 21 hydroxy
ways and it could not be same in this
slide the 21 hydroxylase
was to work in 17 hydroxy progesterone
into 11 the obstacle is wrong with this
patient could not convert rather 17
progesterone will be very high in this
particular child which becomes source of
the testosterone and that results in too
ambiguous genitalia and then the fetus
is exposed to the excess entrance
when the sister of this baby when the
mother was pregnant again was treated
with by the clinicians then the outcome
of a second sister was fine because she
was under the care of replenishing this
proposal I chose that LC ms/ms has a
capability of developing mass spec
method within nine or ten minutes for 10
or more steam oils this is what we tried
in 2000 but number of other labs and
manufacturers of LC intersection again
that you can develop multiple asses and
any ste what combinations you want any
combinations you want you know for
example in this case the 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is also listed in estradiol is
also listed you just have to look at you
need what kind of nothing you need to
develop but else near ms/ms has a
capability you may have been invest into
that you need longer chromatography to
resolve some of the interferences
because they may be isomers of some
steroids this is another example here if
we need limited amount of Steamworks
then you can shock at the method down to
four minutes and you can still add
almost or apply steam roids which would
be very relevant the work of some
patients the sex steroids also have been
known to have problems with the antibody
assays and here is an example from the
data from College of American
Pathologists in Cannes that interesting
dye on the sample which is sent to
multiple labs there was a lab which
reported 17 nano moles or 17 anagrams by
DL but there was a lab which also
reported 23 but look at the estradiol
estradiol was reported as well as 25.7
by one lab but there was one lab which
would have only 227 for the same sample
so we are dealing with the situations
and physicians are not very happy even
the patients go from one lab to the
other lab that our methods are not
standardized among the labs and among
the various manufacture
so beam analysis but if you compare to
LC ms/ms s is here an example of the
testosterone testing being done by CDC
and also done by real here and then if
you compare it and this is the proper
case anemia where your slope is almost 1
and your R square is wrong so before you
change one that fit to the other method
and if your previous method was working
very well this is the kind of comparison
you're expecting for the method
comparison so the endocrinologist have
understood this problem that labs have
these limitations and they have put a
very strong wording into their
guidelines for example this is the
Endocrine Society position statement
which says that we not only need
precision and we also accuracy according
to them that PT testing should be based
on the ability mayor activate Lee which
is going to be very hard for clinical
labs to deliver because different
vendors methods are different that we
don't compare very well to each other
but of course clinicians now are
educated and they're looking for that
there will nothing should only be not
only precise and reproducible but they
should also be accurate here's an
example of estradiol which is a little
bit challenging because the levels of
estradiol and Astro man much lower than
compared to the testosterone so if you
try to make a mass spec method or 10
domestic method for undelivered eyes a
strong arrestor dial it doesn't work
very well so then you need a help to
delimit eyes with a chemical which is
called against I'll call right origin
which enhances the ionizing properties
of the complex here which gives you much
better the intensity but the drawback
would be is when you do beat MMMs on
this 5 or 6 breaks in to 171 which is
part of the derivatized agent since you
are galvanizing a lot of molecules which
are similar to our own as that I are we
171 so you will have people rely upon
only the human signal and that's where
the 10 MMS is helpful compared to just
GCM Sol CMS so of course you required a
good promoter graphing to separate a 1
and a 2 you can use 2 TB label each only
one and now this is a little old method
but you can also buy co-written variable
estradiol and s11 which are almost
perfect because otherwise deuterium have
the depleted exchange so I'm going to
move into an example of what and indeed
which is very popular in the clinical
lab these days and what India is
normally made you expose yourself to the
sunlight
but in America in North America we don't
have a very good Sun won't be coming to
the especially in winters so we don't
make as much vitamin D as before even
the equator so the people who the darks
can also have disadvantage that they
can't make synthesis or to deprive
another hydroxy vitamin D and then the
25 hydroxy vitamin D can also be low
because vitamin D needs to be converted
into 25 if somebody has a liver diseases
or some people are unable to observe
vitamin D then some medications can also
interfere in the absorption than the
conversion of vitamin D 25 hydroxy
vitamin D but the reason literature has
shown interest that vitamin D deficiency
could be associated with multiple
diseases like in psychiatry and
cardiovascular diseases and cancer in
addition to what we have known for a
long time in osteoporosis or Austin or
versus osteoarthritis or rickets this is
just an example what we saw in our lab
there was a rapid increase in interest
or wedding indeed and our warnings
unexpectedly went very high and we had
to make a lot of adjustments in our LCLs
method
to capture this volume this pink here is
listed a sa which should not be already
as normally as to multiply but sometimes
because both testers have vitamin D in
the end the second is I guess in this
ordered so in 1980-81 at mail we used to
do HPLC assay that had a very low
throughput then we convert it to the
idiom in USA because that allowed us
should have a bigger batches but then as
the need went up in 2004 we evaluated
automated analyzer and compare that with
LC ms/ms and we end up making a decision
that we should go with the LC ms/ms and
now go with the automated analyzer or
post like this is just a reminder here
automated analyzer is always attractive
and has a lot of advantages and they
should not be underestimated because a
lot of manual errors can be prevented
when you're dealing with the complex
steve riedel complex hormone then you
have to worry about what are the
possible interferences if you are using
an antibody assay in this case vitamin D
gets converted to 25 hydroxy vitamin D
by the liver and then based upon the
need and the calcium need a small amount
of 45 hydroxy vitamin D will be
converted to 125 dihydroxy vitamin D and
here is a small list of various a bottom
and even related metabolites for which
you would have to make sure whether your
antibody based acids or LCDs as is have
shown that they have no cross reactivity
or the levels are low enough that there
is no clinical impact on the patient
care this was an example here where we
presume that a very popular essay which
was being used by hundred and sixty
three labs gave a mean of 24 milligrams
per ml
but they're very good relatively okay
CBO 15% but when the 24 labs were using
a regular activity-based acid from the
same company
which one has the same antibody but one
was automated one was extracted radium
in USA there was a difference in the
mean value between the two group of labs
for the same sample and the labs there
were portable grabs which were using the
LMS or LC ms/ms essays they were finding
the benefit 812 which was closer to the
radium in USA which was extraction date
but somehow the automated the automated
as they had much higher value so people
who cannot approve LC ms/ms essays have
developed at PLC's UV or HPLC
electrochemical as is the only caution
indoor situation is that you would have
to make sure that you're permitted Rafi
has been long enough that we are away
from the wild volume and most of the
metabolites are separated from each
other and this is a great example
published in 2002 and can that you are
able to separate not only from the d2
and d3 but you can also separate 25
hydroxy epi deeply from 25 d3 there is
an example of the LC ms/ms s is when
your volumes are high you can use
multiple and get PLC's and you can get
results within one minute which is
giving you a separate value for d3 and
d2
and of course you are using to calculate
the unknowns as a ratio with the
internal standards which are available
for both d23 these are some of the
slides that will highlight that LC ms/ms
procedure is manual so you have to be on
the bench you need treat work rules they
have to play their bed and you can use
somewhat semi-auto nation here there is
an example here we are using the
to help the technologists here to pipe
of the sample into the crash plate and
then on the crash plate it gets us on
down and then get wor text and then you
are kind of filtering it here so that
you are able to get the supernatant or
in this case the filtrate into the
bottom plate which can inject it and in
the top you will have some kind of
protein precipitation left and then you
have to make sure that all the process
blend that you can see the sample this
is a very hard to be the very good eyes
and it's a very manual process and then
you trust that you are all the process
Mendel then you put it on VLC and in
this case you put the tray at the right
place and then multiplexing to arms in
our case were injecting samples back to
back and this is the complex at PLC
which is using multiple LC systems for
LC systems and here is a big module
which is helping in getting the samples
done on a timely basis so that we can
report within 24 hours these results
back to the patient in turn back to the
position and this is just a zoom up that
this is a challenging because the leaks
do happen in the lab and the columns do
go bad columns are expensive the
maintenance of this valve is expensive
but if you have chosen this around then
it is something the expertise we have to
build and it could be cost effective if
your volumes are high just some of the
slides highlighting of course compared
to the amino automated amino acids you
have to reveal the tomography and
maintain the pressure of the columns so
it is almost like we have to babysit
sometimes and this is another drawback
here that after if you all do all this
work and you end up collecting a lot of
waste which needs to be disposed of
according to public safety and
regulatory environment and those
regulations this is the dream we all
have that can be taken advantage of the
automated mission
we don't have to do nano puppeting but
instead of using chemical innocence or
fluorescence protection manufacture out
there you can put a mask that detector
into the machine and then give us the
best of the human words this is an
example here that if you using needle
HPLC as your tenant aspect as a that
botha scissor blade I'll comparable to
each other again the slope and the art
scales are very good for both d2 and d3
and then you can use either one of those
two S's throughput for HPLC will be of
course lower than the LC ms/ms acid
there was a study recently done we did
compare different technologies for the
estimation of vitamin D and this
particular paper was plus published in
PLoS ONE in 2010 and their conclusion
was that the most valid method is at PLC
mass spec method compared to the
automated SI or the manual trading
minima assay and some of the data is
shown in this slide here so they just
tested it number of patients by three
different technologies here should be
the same samples have been tested by
three different methodologies and the
point they are making is that if you
test the number of samples by using the
blue line which is the automated amino
acid you a conclusion will be that busy
14:42 or 45 percent of your population
which is below 50 nano moles per liter
of 25 hydroxy vitamin D if you test the
same number of samples by using extract
it read amino acid then the conclusion
will be is it's only 20% of the
population which is below 15 animals per
liter but if you use HPLC si then you
will say that is only the 10% of the
population which is below 15 animals or
20 nanograms per ml as you can see here
there is a huge implication on the
patient care here because if you believe
that the HPLC method is correct and only
10% patient will require vitamin D
supplementation otherwise
42 percent may be given vitamin D
unnecessarily so I would like to
conclude here that both lcms methods and
numeracy methods are very commonly used
and one has the responsibility if you're
the laboratory will have supervisor or
the lab technologist that you have
enough data to support the method you
are using to get the results so it does
have a big impact on the patient care
and then since the LC ms/ms methodology
is becoming popular and a lot of
applications have been published and a
lot of help is available I would
encourage the listeners that you should
consider it and looks at is pluses and
minuses differently decides to bring a
new si in your clinical lab for patient
care I would like to thank for your
tennis thank you very much thank you dr.
Sankar event informative presentation
and for spending time with us here today
I just want to remind our audience how
they can submit their questions
questions can be submitted via the green
Q&A button the lower left of the screen
we'd like to hear from you while we're
waiting for our audience to get their
questions in I just like to pass it back
over to dr. Singh for any concluding or
final thoughts he has about today's
presentation and this field
thank you again now band and all the
attendants really appreciate your time
and email is here we'll be happy to
interact so with anybody I mean my
experience that meal has been that we
implemented this technology but again
they have learnt a lot and we have to
learn still going forward now we are
trying to use this technology for
complex molecules which are proteins and
peptides and antibodies but definitely
the goal here is that all these tools
are available and interesting to make or
make a good selection of the method for
better patient care
thank you thank you again your contact
information is right up there on the
screen so perhaps some of our audience
members will get in touch with you
directly we'd like to thank you again
dr. Singh for being part of today's
presentation we want to let our audience
know that we will be having this
broadcast available on-demand through
May of 2016 you'll be receiving an email
for that and we hope you'll share it
with your colleagues before we go we do
have a question from our audience Bing
from Bing Laboratories asks for 25 hydro
hydroxy vitamin D LC ms/ms test what
kind of cue C's are you using and what
are the batch receptors criteria thank
you that's a great question and I
appreciate the question here we used to
buy the quality control material from a
commercial vendor and the typical
practice in my lab is that you will run
20 internets a precision that is to
determine the value so you don't get the
value from the vendor who makes these
controls so you have to determine your
value before you start using this new C
so you determine for 20 days different
that is and then take it mean and
standard deviation the the QC cv is not
going to be really different or better
what the QC you determined when you were
developing your assay ideally the QC for
the CV of psh
less than 5% but unfortunately we are
not there yet so I would not go higher
than 10% for any QC for any clinical lab
but I know there are exceptions and we
have to work with them and then
hopefully will improve our technologies
and get better assays now because the
quality control material is expensive
when you buy from outside you can always
make your in-house quality control by
spiking in to either base serum or
plasma or you can buy from strip serum
which have very low levels of endogenous
d2 and d3 and you can make your own
controls as well which is totally
acceptable to care thank you thank you
dr. Singh thank you to our audience for
such a good question
remember the presentation will be
available on demand when you hear from
us from lab birds please pass that
notification on to any colleagues who
might have missed today's live event
thank you again for being with us lab
rats , leading scientific social
networking site hope to see you again